hi my name's Pete Hatfield and I studied
maths physics and chemistry at a-level
my question is do you think there's any
strengths than any of the multiverse
theories at the moment and what you
think would constitute empirical
evidence for their existence hi Pete so
you're asking about the multiverse this
is the idea that maybe there are melding
other universes besides the one that
we're in and that may be tied together
or maybe mathematically possible and at
the moment I think we have to admit that
they're mathematically possible but
there is very difficult or impossible to
actually tell if they're true so
according to everything we know we can
only see things in our own universe
would we ever see any evidence that our
universe is not the thing that we think
it is possible yes but it's a hard thing
to think about everything that we know
about our Big Bang says that it is so
intense that it erases almost all
evidence of everywhere else so and the
universe that we see is so large that if
there's another part of it that's
different from ours you know we can't
tell it's just too far away for us to
notice so I think logically it's one
could imagine that there would be a way
found to measure this so far we haven't
thought of a good way